le dernier bébé d'apple sur les fonts
baptismaux on vient de le découvrir
c'est une tablette qui faisait jusqu'à
présent fantasmer tous les amateurs de
nouvelles technologies un patient
forcément de voir la fiction devenir
réalité
ce qui vient de se produire regarder
jérôme bazin samuel gibbons
cette fois ça y est à la une de sienna
me lie à quelques minutes
steve jobs le patron d'apple présente
son nouveau produit qu'il dit
révolutionnaire tablette informatique à
mi chemin du téléphone et l'ordinateur
portable
son nom d'ipad à grand comme une feuille
a4 avec écran tactile
une invention qui suscite d'énormes
attentes en particulier dans la presse
écrite
nous sommes à libération comme ses
concurrents le journal mise sur son
édition en ligne et sur l'internet
mobile pour compenser ces baisses de
ventes
libé s'est même lancée sur iphone
problème le contenu payant n'a que peu
de succès notre vrai problème ce n'est
pas tant les consultations en ligne que
la monétisation puisque la consultation
l'apprenti l'ouverture par jour c'est
pas le problème
en revanche ce qu'on veut c'est de
monétiser à l'intérieur donc en
proposant des parties payantes on le
fait déjà aujourd'hui
mais là on aura un outil qui poussera
certainement certainement encore plus la
monétisation en tout cas c'est ça qu'on
attende à paul à la clé l'idée d'une
édition numérique payante dédiée au
nouvel apple des designers américains
ont déjà imaginé ce journal du futur
loggia fait rêver mais la presse
spécialisée n'y crois pas appliquons
conçoivent les journaux pour 7 pour
cette deuxième pour cette deuxième voie
en fait on le voit donc qu'on change en
fait la façon dont on trouve aujourd'hui
des joueurs c'est vrai que la presse va
mal que
les patrons presse les groupes de presse
cherchent des débouchés grande bande
numérique internet et cette façon de
gagner de l'argent mais là imaginer que
pour un support comme ceux muller dont
doivent totalement changé la façon de
travailler c'est premier handicap
du coup la fabrication de ce super
magazine coûterait pour l'instant plus
chère que celle d'un bon vieux journal
apple voit loin
mais les rotatives ont encore de beaux
jours devant elle